votre invité à présent Karine Becquart
Fanny Lacroix la mère de
châtel-en-triève vice-présidente
également des mers ruraux de France
bonjour Fanny Lacroix
excepté notre invitation les maires des
35000 communes aujourd'hui en France
sont arrivés à mi-manda ils ont été élus
ou réélu en 2020 au tout début
souvenons-nous de la période du covid et
les prochaines échéances municipales
auront lieu dans trois ans autrement dit
au printemps 2026 alors où en sont-ils
dans leur programme ont-ils réussi à
faire avancer leur dossier pas si simple
dans un contexte vous le savez qui
semble pour les élus de plus en plus
tendus et compliqués on a eu envie d'en
parler avec vous Fanny Lacroix mère pour
la première fois de Châtel en Trièves ça
a été dit c'est un petit village en
Isère de 502 habitants seulement parce
qu'il faut savoir qu'en France
70% des maires aujourd'hui sont à la
tête d'une commune de moins d'un millier
d'administrés Fanny Lacroix je voudrais
qu'on parle d'abord du climat dans
lequel vous exercez ce premier mandat
les insultes les menaces les violences
dont il est beaucoup question ces
derniers jours est-ce que vous en tant
que j'ai lu vous y avez déjà été
confronté
oui c'est malheureusement on est
confronté en fait à une forme de
violence qui monte et qui qui gronde de
plus en plus fort et donc c'est assez
paradoxal parce qu'à la fois on est
proche de nos administrés on est
énormément dans le quotidien dans leur
proximité surtout quand on émerve d'une
commune rurale c'est-à-dire que on ne
peut pas y avoir plus proche que nous
comme représentant de la République et
donc on vit des moments d'une intensité
sociale hors du commun qui rend la tâche
extraordinaire et en même temps on a
cette cette violence vis-à-vis de l'État
et de l'institution de manière générale
qu'on soit en montée où on n'a pas
l'impression d'avoir la main malgré le
fait qu'on fasse beaucoup de choses pour
changer la vie de nos concitoyens et
donc oui moi j'ai alors pas de j'ai pas
eu de d'insultes directes mais par
contre j'ai eu il y a à peu près un mois
des caricatures qui ont été diffusés sur
certaines communes proches de la mienne
et sur la mienne aussi et c'est vrai que
j'ai eu du mal à comprendre ce qui ce
qui m'était reproché ça vous arrive
régulièrement où là c'était quand même
un cas à part
non là c'était un cas à part quand même
globalement qui résonne je trouve avec
un certain nombre de d'événements je
trouve que chaque jour on apprend de
nouvelles violences vis-à-vis des élus
de la République et je trouve ça
vraiment vraiment inacceptable
qu'est-ce qui est qu'est-ce qui est le
plus compliqué finalement entre un maire
et ses administrés Fanny Lacroix
qu'est-ce qui est le plus compliqué je
dirais que c'est de pouvoir faire
comprendre qu'on fait de la politique et
que c'est pas un gros mot parce qu'on a
eu quand même moi ce que je note et
vis-à-vis aussi de mes collègues mère
c'est quelque chose que que je remarque
c'est que on n'ose plus dire qu'on fait
de la politique au niveau local alors
que moi je crois qu'en fait la politique
au sens noble du terme c'est nous qui la
porte les maires quand on essaye de
changer la vie de nos concitoyens et
comporte des projets en essayant
d'embarquer tout le monde et donc moi
j'essaye de militer pour cela
c'est-à-dire essayer de raccrocher cet
échelon local où on fait des choses
concrètement à la vision de la politique
et ça c'est très important parce que si
on a cette cassure et bien après ça
emmène tout le monde vers des dérives
que je trouve très délétère donc à
chaque fois j'essaye de rappeler que ce
qu'on fait à l'échelle de la commune
c'est de la politique que la politique
elle nous appartient et qu'on doit tous
être des citoyens actifs dynamiques qui
prennent part en fait à l'oeuvre
collective alors faire de la politique
on l'entend bien mais est-ce qu'un maire
se sent encore suffisamment libre j'ai
envie de dire libre d'agir libre de
faire libre d'avancer ou est-ce que ces
projets se retrouvent toujours assez
rapidement contestée
alors on peut voir le toujours le verre
à moitié à moitié vide moi j'ai plutôt
une perspective de le voir à moitié
plein et donc elle a émerf l'association
des mers ruraux de France on essaie
vraiment de cultiver cela parce qu'on
aurait une tendance mais je trouve qui
est assez généralisée à la France en ce
moment de voir que les que les problèmes
en fait dans nos conditions d'agir et
moi en fait si je suis allé à la
fonction de maire c'est que d'abord je
suis arrivé sur ma petite commune rurale
en tant que secrétaire de mairie et moi
je viens du milieu urbain donc j'avais
aucune connaissance de ce que ça pouvait
être un village et et en arrivant en
fait sur cette toute petite collectivité
je me suis rendu compte c'était que
c'était incroyable en fait ce qu'on
pouvait faire au niveau local et donc
moi quand je fais un petit peu le le
bilan de ce qu'on a pu engager depuis
2014 c'est le jour où j'ai mis les pieds
sur cette commune et où j'ai commencé à
me à m'intéresser à la chose publique
c'est absolument incroyable c'est-à-dire
qu'on a réussi à créer une commune
nouvelle déjà pour pour rassembler nos
capacités d'agir et nos forces ensuite
on a réussi à sauver l'école en mettant
l'enfant au cœur de notre projet
politique donc on a sauvé cette classe
unique et c'était pour le village un
espoir extraordinaire ensuite on a su
construire notre place publique on s'est
réapproprié les espaces publics parce
qu'on est mon village a subi une vague
de désertification donc on a réussi à
concentrer en fait toutes les tous les
tous les efforts citoyens et donc on a
construit une nouvelle mairie un café
épicerie associatif des jardins des
jardins partagés aujourd'hui l'ensemble
des habitants se sentent faire partie du
village on a fait réémerger la commune
au Sens du bien commun vous voyez et
après on a su par cette formidable
énergie déployée collectivement
développer de l'attractivité aujourd'hui
des noms de nombreux porteurs de projets
viennent toquer à la porte de
châtel-en-triève on a ouvert un cabinet
de kiné on a ouvert un salon de coiffure
donc finalement un musée de la
marionnette enfin on peut faire plein de
choses c'est ça que je veux je veux dire
mais du coup c'est quoi la solution pour
que ça se passe bien comme ça entre un
maire et sa population c'est quoi votre
formule c'est quoi votre truc c'est quoi
votre recette comment vous avez fait
c'est que je me place dans une posture
d'animation de mon territoire
c'est-à-dire que je fais pas la
politique seule dans mon bureau avec ma
secrétaire de mairie j'essaye de voir
mon village vraiment comme le comme une
mosaïque de personnes d'énergie qui sont
là et qui nécessite d'être activé
aujourd'hui on peut plus faire la
politique seul aujourd'hui moi je vois
ma fonction comme ma commune comme un
terreau je vais reprendre l'image du
jardin parce qu'elle nous parle beaucoup
à châtel-en-triève j'essaye d'enrichir
le terreau de la commune c'est à dire je
vais muscler notre vision politique
notre capacité à faire les choses mais
je fais pas à la place des gens c'est à
dire je vais offrir partout sur ma
commune des possibilités à l'implication
individuelle et collective et après
c'est les gens qui portent les projets
et je crois que c'est ça aujourd'hui qui
fait la force de Châtel en Trièves c'est
pour ça qu'on a rebaptisé notre commune
châtel-en-triève commune des possibles
c'est qu'on essaye d'accompagner les
projets individuels et collectifs et de
les pousser le plus loin possible alors
c'est pas toujours ça marche pas à
chaque fois mais disons que c'est vrai
que ça moi ce que j'observe depuis
maintenant quelques années c'est que ça
réinsulte dans le cœur des gens une une
capacité à faire des choses ensemble et
je crois que le village vit quand même
globalement plutôt bien malgré la
morosité française qu'on peut qu'on peut
qu'on peut constater aujourd'hui au
final Fanny Lacroix est-ce que ce mandat
de maire ressemble à ce que vous aviez
imaginé ou est-ce que c'est mieux ou
est-ce que c'est pire
alors j'aurais jamais pu imaginer cela
avant comme je vous l'ai dit parce que
moi je viens du milieu urbain et j'étais
un petit peu dans ce que peuvent les
générations qui sont les miennes vous
savez le livre de Raphaël Glucksmann les
enfants du vide moi ça m'a vraiment
percuté c'était ça c'est à dire qu'on
perdait des repères à la fois en termes
de syndicalisme de grandes idées
politiques et même en termes de religion
on a plus ces cadres là qui avant
portait certaines un certain collectifs
et donc moi j'étais là dedans je savais
pas trop comment faire partie de cette
histoire j'avais l'impression de subir
plus d'être acteur mais donc au final
je rencontre mon village et je me dis
ouais à l'échelle du village on peut on
peut faire de la politique c'est ça ça
nous appartient il y a plein de choses
qui sont possibles l'horizon des
possibles et absolument
déterminant quoi alors moi je suis
toujours ravi de d'exercer ma fonction
c'est extraordinaire il n'empêche que
ces trois dernières années il y a 13000
maires quand même 13000 qui ont décidé
de démissionner vous comprenez qu'on
puisse abandonner
oui je comprends parce que c'est vrai
que là j'ai parlé du verre à moitié
plein il y a le verre à moitié vide
c'est vrai que c'est une fonction qui
est qui est difficile parce qu'en fait
et notamment dans ces petites communes
rurales vous devez déployer énormément
d'énergie pourquoi c'est parce que la
réalité d'une commune rurale c'est qu'il
y a pas de service souvent on est un
maire avec une petite équipe et puis une
secrétaire de mairie un agent technique
polyvalent et en fait si vous voulez
déployer toutes ces actions qui sont
essentielles pour l'avenir de nos
villages il faut y mettre de soi donc
c'est passé des heures à la mairie
monter des dossiers de subvention on
peut regretter aussi une logique de
l'État qui est par trop descendante où
on doit monter sans cesse des dossiers
de subvention pour répondre à des appels
à projet ou aujourd'hui malheureusement
et c'est vrai qu'on peut là dessus il y
a de quoi travailler aller vers plus de
liberté communale donc c'est ça c'est
très lourd pour les mères et c'est vrai
que si on n'a pas cette énergie là on
peut vite on peut vite se dire que c'est
pas c'est pas notre portée et en plus
c'est vrai que les violences que l'on
peut voir qui se développe sur
l'ensemble du corps politique va pas
arranger cela ça c'est évident merci
beaucoup Fanny Lacroix vous avez envie
de remplir pour un deuxième mandat vous
savez pour moi
disons que aujourd'hui on engage des
choses à Châtel en Trièves qui qui
mériterait d'être porté dans le temps
mais aujourd'hui moi le message que je
porte aussi à mes concitoyens c'est que
comme je développe la capacité d'agir
d'un collectif qui fait 500 habitants
aujourd'hui il y aura de multiples
maires aussi qui pourront reprendre la
suite si c'est pas moi en 2026 merci
encore